- [Announcer] Middle Ground
is a social experiment
that brings humans with
opposing beliefs together.
These discussions may contain viewpoints
that are the result of misinformation.
Remember to seek out experts
and to be critical of your own biases
while forming an opinion.
Please see the humanity
in each participant
and as always, we encourage empathy.
- There's plenty of people out there
that can separate sex and love.
But for me, when I have sex with someone,
I fall in love with them.
And while I do have friends with benefits,
these people are chosen very
specifically because I know
that I will have to go
through heartbreak on my own
when I have sex with them.
(gentle music)
- [Instructor] Step forward
if you agree with the prompt.
I can separate love and sex.
- For me, I think that I can separate it,
but often times it
doesn't turn out that way.
This is kind of the cliche,
but I do think that sex for
me is better when I'm in love
and when I have respect and
communication with the person.
I also think it depends
on how we define love,
because I could maybe love
that person as a human,
but maybe not in a romantic sense.
So I think there's a
lot of nuance around it.
I'm not really someone who's
gonna say one or the other.
- I also agree with that as well.
When you have those intense
feelings for a person,
the sex definitely hits different.
Knowing that you feel safe
enough with this person
to be emotionally vulnerable
as well as physically
vulnerable with them,
it's a very special bond
that you share, I fell like.
- I really resonate with that
because I'm actually a
survivor of sexual assault
and I'm also disabled.
So I think that trust
plays a really huge role
and that perhaps could
even be more important
than the love factor.
- I think for me, I can
make the clear distinction
because I've had a lot of
meaningless sex in my lifetime
to make me feel good, to
occupy the sense of loneliness.
And then I've loved someone,
but the sex part just hasn't worked out,
but the love is there.
And sadly, relationships like
that didn't work out for me.
And I do agree with what you guys said.
When I'm in love and I can trust someone,
it's better, especially
as a trans individual.
There's a lot of people out
there trying to fetishize.
They don't understand
your body or respect you.
So having the love part
makes it a lot better.
- I love deeply.
The people that are around me feel that.
Love and sex to me are
completely different things.
They absolutely can exist separately.
I hate the fact that even
the polyamory community
is fetishized as well,
and it's like completely sexualized.
It's only about the sex.
Similarly to you, I have sexual trauma.
I have things in my life
that affected me deeply
that I'm still dealing with till this day.
And the fact that it's
automatically just clumped in
is just something that I have to oppose.
(timer ticking)
- Well, I don't believe
this is true for everyone.
Obviously, there's plenty
of people out there
that can separate sex
and love, but for me,
when I have sex with someone,
I fall in love with them.
And while I do have friends with benefits,
these people are chosen very
specifically because I know
that I will have to go
through heartbreak on my own,
when I have sex with them.
- I've been with the same person.
My husband and I were
high school sweethearts.
He's the only person I've ever been with.
And so it would be hard for
me to separate sex and love
simply because I've never had to.
- I think it's also important to note
that some people are maybe asexual.
And so if I have an asexual partner,
which I have not had before,
I would have had that discussion
and it wouldn't have to be integral
to be part of our connection and such.
- My name is Jessica and I'm polyamorous.
To me, relationship anarchy
really has to do with
destructuring our ideas of
hierarchical relationships
in that romantic and sexual relationships
don't have to be at the top.
I think it's actually a lot
healthier to have a community
with our friends, our family,
romantic partners, et cetera.
- [Instructor] My current
relationship status
meets my needs.
- One way I know I'm in the
right relationship with my wife,
we still enjoy texting the
each other, "I love you."
You always start out in a relationship,
oh, I love you, I love you.
And then, are you still
doing that 10 years later?
- We've had, both my fiance and I,
our fair share of struggles
with mental health
in very different ways,
but that understanding and that support.
Even if I do say something
really (muted) up,
even if I do react maybe
radically or violently
during in a panic attack,
he keeps coming back, he keeps trying.
Our love is stronger after
every single disagreement
and every single hurdle.
- So for myself, I practice
the type of polyamory
called solo polyamory,
or sometimes, a style
called relationship anarchy.
And these two styles are
inherently less about hierarchy
and more about autonomy for myself
with my current relationships
or what I'm able to achieve.
It gives me enough flexibility
for me to feel really good
about the things that I
choose to take part in.
And even if I'm in a
relationship that's not so great
or a relationship that
isn't fulfilling to me,
I can still be looking
for other relationships
or maybe I have another
existing relationship
that is more fulfilling
or that actually does support me in a way
that my other relationships don't.
- My name is Randell and I'm polyamorous.
For me, the process of
coming out as polyamorous
was really at me deciding that,
getting out of monogamous relationships
because I had feelings for somebody else
was just not working for me.
I noticed that other
people were practicing
other styles of relationships,
where they were being
truthful to their partners
and admitting the fact
that they had feelings for other people
and doing it ethically.
(timer ticking)
- Currently, I am dissatisfied
with my relationship status
because I did just come out
of a really bad breakup.
So I am single at this point.
And I can be self-sufficient
enough to enjoy my own company,
but it's just in certain moments in life,
like for example, I was
taking a long road trip
and I just imagined my
ex, me caressing her leg
while we're on the road trip.
And you kind of wish that
you just had a person
just to share those moments with.
- So I practice parallel polyamory,
which means that my husband
and I see other people
and we don't necessarily need to meet
or get along with the other
people that we are seeing.
And I love my husband.
I've been with him for 18 years coming up
and I have some friends with benefits,
but I am looking for someone else
to be like in a relationship with
that fulfills some needs
that I'm not getting
from my current partner.
What I've been looking for,
I'm starting to probably determine
that I'm not going to find one person
who is going to fill
the rest of these boxes,
and I may have to separate that up
into multiple other people,
whether it's relationship-wise
or otherwise.
- I'm Bunny and I am polyamorous.
The way that I deal with jealousy
is I like to break it
down and ask myself, why?
Why am I feeling jealous of my husband?
Is it because he's spending
time with someone else
and I need more time with
him or my other partners,
or is it something else?
And once I break it down, I
can then address those issues
such as requesting more
time with that partner
if I am feeling jealous,
that I am not getting
enough time with them,
or I can take it upon
myself to fill said time
with someone else or with another activity
to be able to not focus on
the jealousy that I'm feeling.
- [Announcer] Patriarchy
is the root of monogamy.
- In the little bit of research
I guess that I'd been doing
and realizing that it was
absolutely contractual.
It was absolutely for
gain, advantageous reasons.
It was never love.
- Way back when it was, like
you said, it was contractual.
Women in general were an
object to be purchased.
While that has changed,
that is still rooted in
the system of monogamy
and people thinking they need
to be with someone forever.
- Mmh-hmm.
Yeah, I mean, I think
that's how people stay
in abusive relationships.
(timer ticking)
- I feel like there is a
lot of pieces of monogamy
that are rooted in that patriarchal feel.
However, there are a lot of people
who feel like monogamy is
just the best option for them
and are connected to their
person, regardless of that.
We're thinking about queer
relationships as well
and people who are married to
a partner of the same gender
or outside of the norm.
I don't feel like they are
feeling that patriarchy.
- I don't know if I would
say that it's the reason
that everyone is monogamous.
It does play a role
in just the way that we just
construct our realities.
- But we see monogamy
across so many species,
and that has me wondering.
Obviously, in human society,
it was a big component,
but there's something so much
larger than that monogamy
that reaffirms my belief
that it's not really about the patriarchy.
It's about this inherent need within us,
and some of us lean towards monogamy
and some of us lean towards polyamory,
and that's just the way it is.
- Obviously, I'm a little bit
older than everybody here.
I grew up and really
didn't know much different.
The churches were pretty much,
this is right, this is wrong.
When somebody said polygamy,
I was like, "They must live in Utar."
That's about the only place you knew
where that could possibly exist.
And there was no discussion
of why somebody has that relationship.
We didn't talk about any of that.
- We should make a distinction
that it's not also polygamy.
We are polyamorous.
- Okay.
- So polyamorous and polygamy
are two just different things.
- And See a lot of it is-
- All right, just information and-
- Yeah, I grew up not knowing.
- [Randell] Right.
- [Announcer] It's unrealistic
to commit to being with someone forever.
- So I feel like we spend
a lot of our lives dating
and trying to figure out
who we'd like to be with,
and we don't always get it right.
So I feel like thinking about it that way,
it's unrealistic to think about the fact
that the one person
that you end up choosing
will be your forever person.
It could change in the future.
The divorce rate is very
high in this country.
So I think that's an easy
way to think about it.
- I also think it fits
into that fairytale concept
that this is the one.
And living on a planet that
harbors 7 billion people,
I feel like that's highly unrealistic
that you're just gonna be in love
with just this one
person your entire life.
- My name is Mel and I'm monogamous.
I've just had this self-discovery
that there's so many things about myself
that I just need to work on.
and it's rooted in me just not wanting
to go out of my comfort zone.
And polyamory is definitely something
that is out of my comfort zone.
If I was to try it, maybe
I would actually like it.
(timer ticking)
- I think it really depends on the person.
I mean, I feel like I can
only speak for myself.
A lot of people do stay
together for, say, kids
or something like that,
or perhaps finances.
It's a privilege to be
able to maybe get divorced
or live on one income.
So I wouldn't say that it's a catchall
black and white issue.
- I definitely feel that you
can be with someone forever,
but you're going to change
as individuals as you grow,
and it all depends
on how those changes work with each other.
So if you are able to change
and accept the changes of your partner,
then you can be together forever.
But a lot of people change
not necessarily in a bad way,
but in an incompatible way.
- Yeah.
I would also like to add,
I did believe that I would
have a forever person,
but recent experiences of a
breakup that just happened,
that's what changed my perspective
and I looked at it more logically.
I should be more open to the fact
that I will meet other
people down the line
and I shouldn't assume
that this person is going to
be with me my entire life.
- I mean, I'm polyamorous,
but I've been married
to my first boyfriend
since we were teenagers.
I think that's my forever person.
I believe that for me
and with the waves and with the changes,
yeah, you make that recommitment
over and over again.
And I think that there
can be that forever person
for anyone,
but I also understand
experience plays a role
in that tremendously
and that I haven't had
that experience of loss.
- My opinions of this have shifted.
After being in a really
toxic, bad relationship,
where I really wanted it to be my forever,
but deep down, I always knew
it probably wasn't gonna be feasible.
And then after that relationship,
I didn't wanna be in
a relationship at all.
And this amazing person came into my life,
and I knew, and I tried to push him away,
but it became evident that
that was just my person.
My name is Luca and I'm monogamous.
After being in a polyamorous relationship,
I really knew monogamy was
the route I wanted to take.
There was some jealousy
going on in our relationship
as to how I loved each person
and that couldn't divide it
50-50, and I didn't want to.
I wanna be able to give 100%
of myself to one person.
- Oh, it's kind of making
a sick beat right now.
Hey, good humans.
We can all agree sex and
love are complicated,
but the truth is you can
explore your sexual pleasure
regardless of your relationship status,
including on your own.
That's why we're taking a moment
to thank the sponsor of this video, LELO.
LELO is on a mission to speak
up about sexual pleasure,
break taboos, and remove
stigmas through education.
They are globally recognized
and established as the
luxury pleasure brand
with years and years of leading the way
for personal and partner pleasure.
LELO has a wide idea of toys,
including the Sila Cruise.
But LELO is not just a sex toy brand.
It's a self-care movement
aimed at those who know
that satisfaction transcends
gender, sexual orientation,
race and age.
Because after all, pleasure has no gender.
It's all about taking
pleasure into your own hands
so that you can educate
yourself about your body
and pleasure first to enjoy
sharing it with your partner.
So check out the link in the description
to learn more about sexual wellness
and become part of the self-care movement
that's all about coming together.
Now let's get back into the video.
- [Announcer] The home
environment that I grew up in
set a good example for
my future relationships.
- I think for myself, I grew
up seeing a lot of broken homes
and people who had divorced parents,
and I felt super fortunate
that that wasn't my home life.
And I'm sure it shaped me in ways
that I'm not even able to comprehend.
They were a really good example
of the way that I want
to treat another human.
- My mother, I just remember
her like doing it all.
She was just like the pillar of strength.
And I think just seeing that,
I always thought like, okay,
I can do it no matter what,
and if I have a husband
that can compliment that,
then that's awesome.
My name is Emerald and I'm monogamous.
My husband and I have been
together for 17 years.
And I think that within our monogamy,
if there's an issue that I have with him
that we're addressing it head on
and we're able to fix that
within our relationship
as opposed to introducing other people.
And so I think that over the years,
our foundation has been strengthened
simply because we're able to
communicate to one another.
(timer ticking)
- I grew up, my parents were married.
They've been married from my birth to now.
Eventually my mom stayed
home and my dad kept working,
but he still was trying to be active
in my brother and mine's life.
But as I developed mental health issues
and became a difficult child,
he did not cope well with that
and he peaced out for a bit.
So I don't think that
set a very great example,
because in my greatest time of
need, I would've appreciated
if he stuck by my mom and stuck by me.
So even if it is difficult for
me to interact with my child,
that's not what I want for my future.
- My experience growing up was
definitely similar to yours.
My father was away a lot.
So it was just me and my
older sister and my mom.
And the way that my parents communicate,
it's like their relationship,
they can do pretty much over the phone.
It's that lack of communication
and also having an emotionally
unavailable mother.
It definitely shaped a
lot of codependency issues
on my end.
- My father was an alcoholic
up and through my teenage years.
And when he recovered,
my mother became a really bad alcoholic.
I guess, a good precedent for monogamy,
you stay together with the
same person till death.
They were together until she died,
but it was not good for either of them.
I don't think that they loved each other
at the point in time that I saw them.
All it says to me in that
is don't stay with someone
because you're supposed to,
because you signed a piece of paper
or because you have children together.
You need to take care of yourself first
because you can't be a
good parent to your child,
you can't be a good partner
if you aren't taking care of yourself.
- I grew up in a pretty
religious household.
There were certain ways
that you needed to behave,
certain ways that you
needed to act and be,
and I played that role really, really well
and I was applauded for it,
and I was given
opportunities because of it.
And to step out of that was really hard,
and mainly because my
family was just surrounded
by a lot of secrecy.
We don't talk about things.
We shift them under the rug
and we just bury our
emotions as much as we can
so that we don't really
have to deal with it,
and that is not at all how
I'm choosing to live my life.
My name is Katie and I'm polyamorous.
I struggled with my faith
and also being a polyamorous person
because this is absolutely,
completely frowned upon
in our community.
I was a worship pastor
for many, many years
in a very conservative church.
When I started to just be
a little bit more truthful
with who I was, I had to
really re-wrap my mind
around what I truly conceived God to be
and what that love towards me looks like.
I realized there was just no
way that I could keep hiding
this really important part of myself.
- [Announcer] A polyamorous
relationship is appropriate
for raising a family.
- So I have a six-year-old,
and me and my two partners, we raise him,
and Baltimore City schools knows about it.
My son has an IEP.
So that means he has some
learning disabilities
and there's three people to
support, to be there for him.
So I don't know, I think for me,
just it's allowed me the
freedom to go after goals,
go after dreams and have the
support system still at home.
And I know my son is lacking nothing.
I mean, it's tricky
because you have other
little kids are like,
"Oh, why does Lucas have
two moms and a dad?"
And it's just easy to just be.
Families just look different sometimes.
Just being more open about
it, even that in itself,
is gonna give just more space
for these family structures
to be just respected,
because I know that in my community,
I think we're the only ones
really openly being this way
about who we are.
And we haven't seen any backlash
or anything like that, so.
- Logically, practically,
it does make sense
to have that support.
And we're also talking about
kids when we say family.
I think it expands much further than that.
And so you see people who
already have multiple parents
with stepdads, step-moms.
And so I see no reason that
this is not an addition to that.
So I just wanna put that forth too.
(timer ticking)
- The one thing I heard
is the three of you,
whatever you gotta do,
you're gonna do so he can be successful
and loved and cared for
and feel safe and be safe.
My name is Mike and I am monogamous.
What I love about my wife so much
and makes our marriage special
is A, she puts up with me,
and we have found ways
that we support each other
with what we like to do professionally
and spiritually and help out.
And I think that's a lot
of what I took away today.
I saw that with the other side.
- So, as for my household,
we have five children.
Our parents live 2 1/2 hours away.
So it's mainly us doing the
brunt of the school pickups,
drop off, all that kind of stuff.
While I do see that it
would be very beneficial
to have someone else,
I think that's why nannies are available,
babysitters, that kind of thing.
Trying to add someone
else to our lifestyle
would make me so anxious.
It would just be like, "Oh my gosh,
there's another person in the
house that needs something,
that has to do something;
and then somebody else
to have to deal with,
and then they possibly want sex tonight."
I would be like, "I'm over it," so.
- I mean, that's why,
(interviewees laughing)
that's why Google calendars exist.
I get what you're saying
and that there is like a lot of that
in the polyamorous community,
where you're interested in someone
and they're like, "Hey,
look, I really like you,
but I just don't have
the bandwidth right now
to add another partner."
But at the same note,
if you or your husband
got another partner,
they could watch the kids
while the two of you
go out on a date night.
That would add time for
you and your husband
to be able to go off,
'cause they could be
integrated into the family.
- [Announcer] All right, we can cut.
(gentle music)
(interviewees clapping)